Bình hả các quan hệ ngoại giao với thấy lan của chính phủ các vü chiên ngày emy từ tháng bởi
Đánh giấu bước ngoại đáng loại trong quan hệ sông tuân vốn nhiều lần dưới và khăn thẳng,
cho chánh chấp lãnh phổ và mốt thận lịch sử.
Chính phủ hằng gia các vü chiên đã quyết định hả các quan hệ ngoại giao với thấy lan xuống mất bị thứ thứ 2
và chở hồi tăng thế nhân viên ngoại giao đang làm việc tại dài sự quan các vü chiên ở bằng câu nốt.
Các nhà ngoại giao thấy lan cũng được ước câu dơ các vü chiên.
Động thấy này được đưa ra chỉ sau vài giờ khi thấy lan chỉ ở môi đại sử và yêu cầu về căn vü chiên giúp nhân sự ngoại giao với nước.
Mình nhân sự phép là vụ nổ biên tại khu vực biển giới chân chấp khiến năm bị sĩ thấy lan bị thường.
Thái lan là tức đón cự ở tòan bộ các cự ở đông bắc.
Và khi khạt kế hoạch kệ khẩn các cündo ý tình sự giống trong cuộc xung đồ tăng hàng nghị thông chân mềm mô tạc đền Priya Vihas,
cho khi các vü chiên cảo vệ thái lan và nướng quan mất,
phía thấy lan là nhân mạnh việc xem xét lại quan dễn quan hệ.
Dựng biển mời nhất, căn làm giới liên lo ngại khi cündo ý thái lan và căn vü chiên giận đã sẻ ra đủng độ của trang giọc thè của vực biển giới chân chấp và sã ai này tự tháng bài.